[Musik]
ja die medizin kann ich auch aber kannst
du den text morgenroth für mich braucht
keine nationale feiertage also ich finde
ja dass die schweiz ein sehr eigenes
land ist mit der eigenen tradition und
wenn man sich darauf besinnen will kann
man den ersten august dafür zum anlassen
ist nämlich braucht es nationen nicht es
braucht kulturräume heidi heigl hast du
hier die eigentlich mal gelesen nein ich
habe heute nicht gelesen hast du hast
die liegt hier im stroh in ganz
einfachen archaischen verhältnissen und
sieht auch ein bisschen aus wie nicole
und schaut auch ein bisschen aus wie ich
und ist auch so glücklich dazu liegen
und sie braucht gar nicht viel zu hause
bin ich da wo ich nichts brauche man
braucht nix weil man schon so viel hat
da wo man zu hause natürlich ist es
nicht so dass du auf einem schiff als
flüchtling zu hause bist aber wenn du
jetzt als heidi in den bergen mit den
ziegen und dem käse und dem großvater
bezugspersonen und unten im bett und
nimmt aber schon ziemlich viel natürlich
das sind die essentiellen dinge des
lebens aber mehr braucht es dann auch
nicht zum glücklichsein als heimat da wo
die welt in ordnung ist heimat ist da wo
geborgenheit ist heimat hat natürlich
als begriff eine schwierige verbindung
weil es hat was mit vaterland zu tun und
mit patriotismus und mit rationalität
und trotzdem finde ich es wahnsinnig
wichtig einen ort zu haben wo man
aufgehoben ist und das ist für mich die
heimat deswegen ist es auch so schwierig
dass jetzt die ganzen flüchtlinge
sozusagen verlustig werden ihre heimat
das ist ja ein aspekt der auch wichtig
ist es geht ja nicht nur um heimat haben
soll es geht ja auch im heimat verlieren
für mich ist heiß hat nicht sozusagen
eine ehe sondern es ist wie heißt es so
schön bei dem partnerschaft die reelle
monogamie wenn du das lebensabschnitts
heimat das so ist in reinheim meine
heimat ist definitiv hier in zürich es
gibt auch so eine art von liebevollen
genervt sein
vor dem herzen ja zum beispiel von mir
oder wenn ich zurückkomme nach zürich
und dann ist altpapier abholtag und ich
wie diese mit dem
winkel maß angefertigten altpapier starb
aus denen man direkt wieder neues haus
bauen könnte oder dass man weiß die
öffentlichen verkehrsmittel sind sehr
pünktlich aber wenn zum beispiel die
erste schnee fällt bricht sofort alles
zusammen diese ambivalenz von zwingli
amische repression und dem leichten irre
werden das drückt sich auch in diesem
zeitungsstapel ausschluss aus